can't miss this story according to the
new york post
there is a new york parent who wants to
marry
his or her own child
we do not know whether this individual
is a man or a woman
this parent because the person who has
filed this court document
has wants to remain anonymous because
obviously this person is a sicko
and we also don't know the sex of the
child because in the last five or seven
years we've redefined marriage
fundamentally redefined marriage to take
sexual difference out of it so we don't
know is it a daughter is it a son we
don't know here's what we do know
as a matter of quote individual autonomy
this parent uh wants to remain anonymous
because
what what he or she wants is quote an
action that a large segment of society
views is morally socially and
biologically repugnant
um but what this person wants is quote
through the enduring bond of marriage
two persons whatever relationship they
might otherwise have with one another
can find a greater level of expression
intimacy and spirituality and therefore
this person wants to marry his or her
child
that language maybe intentionally so
is the language of anthony kennedy's
decision
in obergefell v hodges the decision that
redefined marriage from the court bench
to include monogamous same-sex unions
the question i i wonder if this is a
troll i wonder if this parent suing to
marry his or her own son or daughter is
is doing so to make a point or maybe
it's real though i mean this sort of
creepy stuff does happen a lot in our
culture
regardless the question i have is
by the logic of obergefell by the logic
according to which the supreme court
specifically anthony kennedy
redefined marriage to include monogamous
same-sex unions
why should this matter be any different
why should these people be excluded from
this important bond of marriage
why should these people's individual
autonomy
between consult consenting adults who by
the way can't procreate
it says in the court documents they
can't procreate so who knows maybe it's
an age thing maybe it's a sex thing who
knows
why should they be excluded for that
what's the argument
what's the argument well because it's
it's wrong well that's what you say but
you know that's just your opinion man
come on man
that's just your value system maybe
people have other value systems
isn't doesn't marriage expand intimacy
well uh antonin scalia had a great line
about this which is he says you know
anthony kennedy says that
marriage expands intimacy but as someone
who's been in a long time marriage i
i think actually marriage uh restricts
rather than expands
intimacy ask the nearest hippie
which is a great line marriage expands
spirituality what does that mean
i have no idea neither does kennedy
neither does the person writing this
but what's the limiting principle there
isn't one
so then maybe we need to rethink some of
the radicalism that we've engaged in in
the last
few years not because we hate people not
even
first of all not because we hate
homosexuals
right no one's saying we we need to
outlaw homosexuals
no one's saying that at all but what the
left has done because they're so smart
about this
they conflate these two things they say
well if you don't want to radically
redefine the fundamental political
institution and cultural institution by
the way
the building block of society the family
if you don't want to fundamentally
redefine it from what it's been for all
of human history everywhere on earth
then you hate gay people and you want to
ban them and you don't want to let them
do anything and you're you're mean what
what are you talking what are you
talking about
well what they're talking about is using
language
a topic i talk about at great length by
the way in uh speechless controlling
words controlling minds available now
for pre-order
using language to redefine these
cultural questions and these political
questions and then
bullying you the conservative tricking
you the conservative
into only focusing on the cultural
matters where by the way
they're not the le the right is not
wielding power anyway
and totally conceding the political
realm
seems like a big trick seems like we
should wake up to it and start fighting
back if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
you